nina who are your favorite and least
favorite doctors from the tv show
doctors who
doctors who yes like attorneys generally
what it's called yeah
um all right well i should start this
with a disclaimer which is that i
watched only the new
modern iteration of doctor who and then
i stopped
i think i might have watched one or two
episodes of peter capaldi but not much i
kind of fell off at the end of the matt
smith era i'm gonna jump in and say that
that almost exactly mirrors my
experience except i precisely stopped
watching
about halfway through the first peter
capaldi episode i watched
oh halfway through okay strong statement
yeah so go ahead and tell us what you
what you think
so the
it's funny because the first doctor who
that i was exposed to was
my least favorite and i feel like this
is probably going to carry some
controversy but i
i didn't like christopher eccleston and
it's not because i don't like
christopher eccleston it's because i
think he's a great actor and i loved him
on the leftovers
g.i joe the rise of cobra anybody yes
another classic performance
oh boy
and he was i'm like i know these
yes god he was in thor the dark world
another movie i don't like
he also didn't like it
so that's why i don't like him as doctor
who didn't like doing it and you could
tell he just was kind of
unhappy oh nina you can't say you like
to ask doctor who this is
this is exactly how wars start you can't
go on the internet and call the
character doctor who what are you doing
what are you doing nina his name is
i know what his
not name is i don't recall that he hated
it but i think that there was friction
that made it there was friction and he
left after one season and it was like it
just i always maybe this was kind of
biased and colored by the fact that then
i read a bunch of stuff of eccleston
being like i really didn't want to do it
for more than one season and i felt kind
of you know pressured because typically
people stay a lot longer than one season
right for the majority of the people who
have played the doctor um so i would say
out of the modern iterations just
because he had the least fun with it i
mean he took it super seriously and
there's something to be said about that
and he plays a very grizzled angry
harsh doctor but he's a ptsd doctor yeah
but i was also like this is a
originally it is a show for kids you
know a lot of things that are four kids
are also enjoyed by adults harry potter
is a kid series for god's sake and
plenty of adults like harry potter
lord of the rings everything um
everything we all like is originally
probably for kids comics
um
right so
and i was just like i don't want to see
like a sports i don't want to see a
grizzled ptsd veteran travel through
time i want to see someone with some
levity and some hearing about it which
is why david tennant is far and away my
favorite doctor who
um sure he's he also has some of the
best companions
as the doctor which is his name
that's his name the doctor no he has i
think he has of anyone the most fun with
the role which is also a nice contrast
to that i think he has like the saddest
exit and some of the saddest moments i
remember bawling when he and um rose
billy piper's companion have to split up
he also has some of the best companions
i know that nobody liked martha i love
mark but really you like i felt like she
was really unpopular but i i really
liked donna and i really liked uh rose
and so i was like he has two of the
strongest companions he has some of the
best episodes he has like episodes like
blink which link's the best one yeah the
best episode that's the one that's the
one you show to people who've never
watched doctor who and never will watch
doctor who you're like just watch this
one episode and you'll be in fun fact uh
i have a funko pop of a weeping angel
and it's lost in my apartment and i
haven't been able to find it in years so
that's how i'm gonna die one day is that
you'll yeah it'll get you when you're
it's gonna get me it's for for saying
the wrong name for this entire episode
that's why it will get me
yeah to a time when i knew better um but
yeah i mean david tennant is such a
charming actor anyway even when he's
playing a villain and jessica jones i'm
like oh i don't know he's i like i just
like to watch him and he just has that
irreverence and that joy and so much
good spirit as the doctor
um and i was sad to see him go and i
thought matt smith was pretty good but
he was also
younger and sadder which was a weird mix
for me but
yeah i mean david tennant
is
is far and away my favorite doctor i
think that's probably a pretty standard
response to that question i have a
similar response which is yeah for me
david tennant was the guy who like
made me love the doctor to me kind of
like when i think of that show i think
of david tennant not anybody right i i
like christopher eccleston just fine i
liked him a bunch actually um yeah and i
would that's fine i would love it if he
like there was they did that special
where um
matt smith and david tennant teamed up
as their respective versions of the
doctor and hung out with the war doctor
the secret yeah john hurt yeah yeah um
yeah there were rumors that christopher
eccleston would come back but it just
didn't work out and that would have that
would have made my day um so for me my
favorite also is david tennant i really
liked him a bunch i liked matt smith
next as the doctor but i don't think i
liked his episodes very much i would
agree with that i think his story lines
were super unnecessarily confusing in a
certain way really confusing and i was
like what is even going on yeah
i love river song and so i was
disappointed because i was like i love
watching river song and erect doc but i
don't know what's happening how did
right how to take it how to take a
character who's interesting and make her
less and less interesting because
everything's getting confusing
everything's going up its own but in
terms of continuity the stories made
less and less sense so i think for me
even though i have fond memories of matt
smith as the doctor overall those
storylines were the ones that kind of
started making me less and less
interested in pursuing it so
that's when that comes to when i started
watching the peter capaldi doctor i
literally it had been like
maybe a year or two since i watched
doctor who and peter capaldi had already
been on for a couple seasons and so um
it was on netflix at the time and so i
was like let me get back into doctor who
let me check this out let me see this
peter capaldi as the doctor and so for
like the first chunk of the episode he's
in bed unconscious and every and he's in
victorian england and there's a the
dinosaur ladies just like ah the doctor
needs to heal but there's a dinosaur
loose in london
and then
and then he wakes up and he's like
wandering through the streets of london
and he hears the dinosaur roaring and
he's like i'm coming i'm coming to help
you and he was like really sad about
this crying dinosaur and i literally at
that point i was just like
i don't care about this at all i don't i
have no emotional connection to a sad
dinosaur in england in the 19th century
um this is dumb and i'm not interested
in this anymore and i just quit and i
had like i had watched a lot of the
modern era at least of doctor who i
followed along i really cared about the
characters i was really into all of it
and then by the time this rolled around
i just was like i'm done so for me my
least favorite is peter capaldi because
in the few minutes i watched him be the
doctor i stopped watching this series as
a result i'm sure he's fine i'm sure
that overall there's a lot i missed out
on but at the same time i don't feel
especially compelled to go back
yeah and i feel guilty that i can't
bring jodie whitaker into it because i
truly have not watched any of her
episodes as the doctor which is a shame
because i really like jodie whittaker uh
she's great on she's great on broad
shirts she's great in black mirror like
if you've watched any of the other you
know british gritty tv stuff that she's
done she's great um but and i also want
to give a shout out to like i was
talking about companions earlier my
favorite companions are amy and rory
which is funny because my doctor is
david tennant but amy and rory are far
away my favorite companion amy and rory
were great that was when the show
started kind of like it was like on the
edge of it was believing its own hype
too but also kind of it was delivering
but also not where it was getting like
more and more cinematic more and more
bold but at the same time the story was
really just kind of going in and out of
of doctor who lore instead of just kind
of telling good stories and
needlessly confusing stories about the
doctor rather than stories that the
doctor is participating in so yeah i was
like i don't need that much of his of
the doctor's backstory i'd rather just
see him explore time right it's it's
tough because i think like part of me
wants to say matt smith is my least
favorite because that was the run
that i got less and less interested in
but i think he's so
fun and i hope i always kind of give him
a pass no matter what he's in i even
like i even didn't mind him in
terminator genesis when he was skynet he
shows up as skynet at the end right and
i was just kind of like all right matt
smith this movie is awful no i mean i
didn't even mind him in the crowd in the
one of the most boring seasons of the
crown ah yeah which is like the first
season yeah i like the crowd doesn't get
juicy until you bring diana into it i'm
sorry come on let's get real but yeah
matt smith is a lovely actor i'm excited
to see him in-house with the dragon
eventually when that happens and
but yeah i just think the writers didn't
do him any favors as the doctor yeah it
got worse as time went on um
wouldn't it have been great if he pulled
out a sonic screwdriver on the crown
just been like i'm here to fix it i
would have loved that diana's not going
to die on my watch yeah
i don't know i don't even know who he
played i didn't watch the show
i assumed i assume he played diana's uh
cousin i don't know nope he played the
the he was like in the first couple
seasons when uh elizabeth and her
husband her late husband and philip are
young he plays a young
young so by the time diana's on the
scene they didn't they didn't put him in
old age makeup they just got an older
app no they keep switching the actors
that's the that's the queen's gambit of
the crown and with that i'm finished
all right tom
can you tell us about your you've been
very quiet this whole time letting nina
and i
dig a doctor who
phone booth shaped grave yes i'm calling
it the doctor who phone booth i know
it's called the tardis i don't care uh
thanks for taking this bullet with me
ryan
yeah
who are your who are your
most and least favorite doctors who
you like and dislike
[Music]
that was slick as snot is what that was
yeah
i felt hesitant to to say anything i
think you guys know
me pretty well you know that i'm not
into geek stuff
uh
so i wasn't i wasn't like crazy familiar
with doctor who going into this uh so
like i i did like 15 minutes of research
just to like figure out
what the show's actually about
it felt like
there were kind of a
an intimidating number of people that
played the doctor uh going into this so
like picking which one was objectively
the best
uh
if it felt
difficult but then like like i said i'd
like i did like a little bit of reading
and uh it's actually like it's super
simple i put together like a quick chart
every time tom says he's not prepared
it's never true
yeah no i'm totally prepared i just like
i didn't know very much about this thing
going into it so i i i read into it and
it is it's pretty simple right like
you started out back in the 60s with
william hartnell then he went to the
peter trout and they they did the the
second doctor uh they developed the
whole idea of regeneration then he went
into john pertwee for the third doctor
he had tom baker for the fourth doctor
he was kind of a fan favorite he brought
in like the scarf and the yo-yo and the
jelly
he was the one with the the scarf right
the famous scarf yeah john baker he had
the great big scarf yeah yeah yeah that
like people still wearing a convention
yeah yeah yeah it's an iconic thing
apparently
yeah peter davidson from uh
all creatures great and small he he took
over as the fifth doctor then he went
into colin baker which was kind of a
rough period for the show uh sylvester
mccoy
the show gets canceled
they go in they do the fox movie in the
90s where uh eric uh what's his name
robert eric roberts aircraft
turns into it yeah a ton of eyeliners
like just wow just terrific if you
haven't seen it it's it's uh
it's supposed to be spectacular then
there's the hiatus they go into uh
the ninth doctor christopher eccleston
who you talked about a little bit and
then david tennant and uh
matt smith peter capaldi and then of
course uh jody whitaker who just
recently announced that she's not gonna
do the show anymore uh so then you know
whoever comes next but it's really just
those 13
people to pick from what about john hurt
as the war doctor
okay i didn't i didn't think yeah okay
so i guess like in the 50th anniversary
especially they do they introduce john
hurt he goes between
what eight and nine right here so
there's
that and then at the end of the 50th
anniversary special of course they bring
back tom baker playing the uh the
curator the mysterious
employee of the shadow gallery so he's
like he's somewhere out in the future
over there uh recently uh with the jody
whitaker years they did they introduced
the idea of the fugitive doctor and that
the doctor
had a bunch of regenerations before okay
the first one which then of course that
you get like the seven different
iterations so the time was children
those are all in there uh
then you get into the ancillary
characters so like you've got a doctor
who in the curse of fatal death that's
uh 1999.
so tom i want to reiterate you're not
very familiar with this show you've
never heard of have you watched much of
it yeah not a huge geek
not big into geek stuff but
okay
got it thanks for watching please hit
like and subscribe and leave a nice
comment so you don't make us cry